something that newspapers are covering
today is the meeting between MPs that
will be happening to discuss how best to
respond to that damning report that came
out last week claiming there was a
widespread culture of bullying and
harassment within Westminster now dozens
of current and ex parliamentary staff
who have reported bullying have waived
their right to anonymity to sign an
unprecedented opal letter calling for
urgent change
we're I'm pleased to say that the set
Whitacre added her name to that letter
and she joins me now to tell us her
story of harassment in Westminster good
morning to you Lisette now it's very
brave of you to go public so we really
appreciate you coming in the sonne thank
you and now this report said there is a
culture of widespread bullying it is
described as a real problem
what was your experience of working in
Westminster um well I started my
Westminster career back in about 93 and
I think it was fairly immediately really
the I experienced sort of low-level
harassment nothing he could really sort
of put your finger on and say that is
actually a sort of harassment and issue
moment yeah I joined the European
scrutiny committee and and they were
people would make comments when I walked
into the cafeteria about well here come
here come the Euro babes and I was only
sort of 19 at the time and it was it was
quite off-putting and MP jumped into a
lift with me on my sort of second or
third day and said he'd be really happy
to show me around all the bars and it
just sort of this low-level stuff that
just felt like it it was all the time
but you feel uncomfortable yes it did
make me feel uncomfortable I had other
members of teams coming to me saying all
come and work for me I can pay you
whatever you want if you can't only come
and work for me and and that happened
quite a lot this particular person kept
coming in
and but then in a round sort of 94/95 I
was assaulted
I can only say now by an MP and I did
report it but nothing was done in fact I
was it was brushed under the carpet it
was made to sort of made out that it was
a sort of minor minor incident and what
did I expect and what did I want them to
do about it because yeah because
presumably there is well was there a
procedure in place there was no HR
process there were no HR structure I
told my manager and in fact I also had
some issues with him he was he used to
shout at me quite a lot our offices were
next door to each other and he would
shout rather than pick the phone up and
ask me to go in or come in and see me he
would just shout my name until I went in
one occasion I went in and he said oh oh
I just want to tell you it's a really
nice dress that you've got on this it's
the person that you had to report an
assault to yeah he was the only person I
could report it to doesn't mean anyone
else and there was an HR department but
that was it was made clear that was for
members and members staff it wasn't for
House staff he was you were sort of not
there wasn't any way for you to go
basically so so I said that to him and
that was his response and I felt very
vulnerable
I felt very exposed but I also felt like
I just needed to toughen up a bit and
this sort of word resilience has been
banded around quite a lot and I think
you were made to feel that you needed to
be resilient if you need if he wanted to
get on in that organisation and
obviously that is not the definition of
resilience is putting up with that kind
of behavior but at any point feel you
should go to the police did you ever
consider that oh well and this was as I
say in the 90s
after I contacted Andrea led some to
tell her my story I got a response to
say you should go to the police so I did
so I went to the police quite recently
because at the time you wanted to keep
your job I wanted to keep my job and I
because it would play down oh this is
how everyone everyone has this and one
comment that I've read in the paper you
haven't earned your stripes until you've
been assaulted but it's Italy and that
that's exactly how it felt it felt that
this was just part and parcel of that
culture of this very sort of insular
culture and that's what this report that
came out last week demonstrated that
this is widespread is endemic it seems
to be in the fabric of Westminster
absolutely when you were going through
your ordeal did you speak to your
colleagues about any experiences they
might had have did you see other things
going on around you to make you feel
that you weren't the only one oh yes
absolutely I wasn't the only one I mean
I told people about the incident with
that MP because he then went on to stalk
me for years
and nothing was done about it and like
day to day was awful I used to hide for
if I thought because he worked in the
same building as me so I used to hide on
the same floor actually so if I saw him
I would I would you know make a beeline
for the loo or I would hide or he would
find me and and I mean he you know he'd
make a beeline for me in in staff
cafeteria and he would come and sit with
me yeah yeah they see still in
Westminster now no but he yeah he would
sort of make a beeline for me and my
friends knew oh god here he comes
they would know to to help and they
would sort of we would sort of share our
experiences of members behaving badly
but it was just you were just made to
feel as if you just had to get on with
it you just had to suck it up because at
the end of the day it's not really that
big a deal there are more important
things that's that's the message there
are more important things we were
written about so it's always the price
that women and some men
have to pay for a career in Westminster
lately yeah I mean some of what you're
describing to me we're not talking about
one-off incident no instance we're
talking about your daily work your life
yeah being affected yes my bullying yes
harassment yes and it affects me now
yeah how am I you know and I struggle
I've been diagnosed with PTSD
I have sleepless nights yeah I mean you
know this is really scary to come to
come and do this but it's so important
because I don't think people appreciate
how damaging it is to people and that's
that's the message I wanted to kind of
get across is that this is affecting
everyday people that it's affecting
their lives it's affecting their careers
you know I I felt there was no choice
but for me to leave the house because I
couldn't cope with it any longer and
that must be so disappointing for you in
terms of I would imagine going into
Westminster you imagined a long lasting
worthwhile career it's a career for life
and you you know I really value the
importance that Parliament plays I loved
working for an institution that was
doing such good work it was really
important to me I was passionate about
my my job was passionate about doing
something of value and and yeah so it
did feel like it was going to be for
life we're doing something positive now
in terms of you using your experience to
speak up with the Solidarity of others
who have been through the same thing to
help women in politics to help women in
Westminster and men who are vulnerable
as well we've had stories of men who
have been through similar experiences
what do you want to come from this
report in this discussion that's
happening today and going forward and I
want I want historic cases to be looked
at because I not alone there are lots of
other cases that weren't even looked at
there are lots of people that have
grievances I'm sure that haven't you
have a chance to talk about them so it's
really important for me that historic
cases are looked at I want an apology
really I want I want someone to take
responsibility for what's happened and I
want management to accept that there
there is a problem